Alors attention vu que cette vidéo parle de la série Stranger Things elle contient forcément quelques spoilers
En fait l'histoire elle se passe dans les années 80
Ouais enfin c'est plus les années 80 américaines quoi
ouais voilà c'est mieux
Bon en gros c'est un groupe de potes, enfin pote enfants, ouais alors là on dirait pas mais bon faut imaginer qu'on est des enfants
et puis un jour Will, l'un d'entre eux, disparaît après avoir été attaqué par des choses étranges
qu'est ce qu'un enfant de 11 ans prendrait instinctivement pour se défendre ? je sais pas une épée en bois ?
un doudou magique? Oui non mais aux USA. Ah, une carabine à balles réelles. Yeah c'est bien ce que je me disais DONALD TRUMP!
Et puis soudain hop une enfant mystérieuse apparaît
il pleut pas mal dans cette région hein, un peu quoi
bon et puis bon bah la fille elle a un prénom un peu bizarre
En fait il voudrait savoir comment tu t'appelles
Onze ?
JCVD : alors attention un plus un ça fait pas forcément onze
ça fait deux
mais peut-être que dans l'Upside Down là ça fait onze, alors on devient selfish,
on mange beaucoup on prend du poids, hein le gros hein
mais dans la vraie vie, moi je suis Jean-Claude Van Damme et dans l'Upside Down peut-être que je suis un nobody je suis pas une movistar
mais en vrai dans la vérité vraie.... (Jean-Claude se fait dégager)
après des méchants scientifiques veulent récupérer Onze et sont prêts à tout pour y arriver
Bonjour,  je suis l'assistante sociale
Bonjour
je viens pour la gamine
c'est bizarre vous n'avez pas la même voix qu'au téléphone
AH LA FERME
Mais maintenant Onze,  elle traîne avec le groupe de gosses
ça fait deux semaines que t'es chez moi et t'as pas prononcé une seule phrase.
Ils t'ont rendue muette c'est ça ?
ah non je t'aime pas c'est tout
ah ok
moi j'aime que les gaufres
et depuis l'autre monde, Will commence à communiquer avec sa mère grâce à une petite technique
Il faut changer les ampoules ?
Alors là Onze elle commence à aider les enfants à chercher Will, alors qu'ils jouaient tranquillement à un petit jeu de plateau
Will est là
Les autres joueurs ragent...
Bon clairement la mère de Will elle est pas bien
ouais elle est un peu tendue
Will ? C'est toi Will ?
on peut dire qu'elle est proche du burn-out
Will ?
C'est toi Will ?
J'arrive !
Bonsoir, il y avait une porte d'entrée en fait là-bas
Bah je dis ça parce que..
ça va sinon ?
et alors là truc de ouf, les enfants ils prennent une radio et il arrive à contacter l'Upside Down
t'as raison Dustin, ces sons proviennent certainement de l'autre monde
chut ! Attendez il y a vraiment un truc
Salut mes petites beautés, c'est Cyril Hanouna ! J'adore ! Ce soir dans TPMP j'vous dis on est pas en rassrah les chéris
Et là incroyable twist, le flic fini par retrouver le corps de Will
je sais que c'est pas Will
t'es entrain de devenir complètement folle avec cette histoire
je te dis que c'est Will
enfin il y a marqué made in china derrière
bon à un moment les enfants ils habillent Onze en fille, même si elle était déjà en fille, pour que personne ne la reconnaissent
Pas mal, vraiment pas mal
Ouais t'es sublime !
C'est clair
Je suis là hein
Oh nan ! Vas-y !
c'est moi
moins bien
Et alors pour la saison 2, euh, on imaginait des guest stars mortes mais qui redeviendraient vivantes
Venez les enfants c'est de l'innocence
Dah hi hi (Ce que fait Michael Jackson)
Ta gueule Michael même (?) n'en n'a rien a foutre
Hola, c'est Pablo Escobar, je ne suis pas mort, je vous ai niquez, j'étais dans l'Upside Down avec les petits monstres
on jouait , je leur donnais de la poudre
Hey, Mike como esta el nino ?
hum.. un dos tres
Ouais et pis genre maintenant, eh bin les monstres ils se sont vachement intégrés, tu vois ?
hey, salut Jacqui, salut Michel
et puis et bas à la fin ça se transforme en comédie musicale
eh j'ai rien fais !
vous n'avez pas le droit !
En gros c'est comme ça qu'on imaginait la saison 2 de Stranger Things
Musique épique
ouais Titouche tu peux arrêter de synthé steuplais
Pourquoi vous parlez anglais et nous français ? Comment ça se fait ? C'est magique où..?
Never ! ne- yeah
nan ça veut dire jamais
ouais, je, ah non, mais c'est pas, c'est pas..
*siffle*
le melon quoi ?
bon ça va nous aussi on est américains
non, on n'est pas américains
ouais ouais, on est pas américains mais euh
bon, bah goodbye
Et sinon, vous connaissez le Woop ?
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, abonnez vous à ma chaîne YouTube
on est à quelques millimètres de passer la barre des 10 millions d'abonnés youtube
Oh my god !
c'est vraiment maintenant ou jamais
GO TO 10 MILIONS !
Sous-titres par Othmane Ech-chabbi